dave chappelle's netflix special has
become the focal point of the media in
this country it is not the uh rapidly
rising prices of utilities of food
it is not the massive homelessness
problem
it is not the inability of uh the
government washington to function
uh it is not any of those things it is
the dave chappelle
netflix special
where there are
employees of netflix who are angry at
this uh staging a walkout of the special
so
it is a special that i full disclosure
i've not seen all of i watched a little
bit of it
you know he's a master was it the
funniest thing in the world no
is he is he expressing an opinion held
by the vast majority of human beings
about men and women yes
um
but the ceo of netflix ted sarandos
who's greek right i believe so
interesting
so uh
because there's not a lot of successful
greek people
there's really not that's true the vast
majority of greeks are are not doing
well
but some of them are right they own
diners but there were working-class
people
and ted sarandos
good for him it's john stamos there's a
few of them a couple yeah rita wilson
tom hanks his wife
it's not a huge group
so ted sarandos
greek
giannis babas greg uh defended dave
chappelle and said listen guys
um we're gonna put out things you may
not like them we don't think it's gonna
lead uh to uh
real world violence against trans people
that was basically the gist
of his
uh
statement
um netflix chief
again defense chappelle special quote
content doesn't directly translate to
real world harm he said we have dave
chappelle on our platform we also have
hannah gatsby and then hannah gadsby who
we don't know where she's been she's
somewhere in australia and forcing a
lockdown i'll tell you that much where
is she she's in new zealand right
blinking
anyway hannah gatsby who's
she's atypical neurodivergent whatever
she's not always with us and when she is
with us she says some very disturbing
things and then goes back to where she
lives and that's great but she doesn't
really know what's going on she's kind
of fuzzy it just seems like she's like a
fuzzy photograph right her hair is never
quite
she's just caught of law and this is the
way it is mullen does it great
impressive her but every now and then
she gets real fired up you know when
someone insults greta thundberg or
whatever she gets real fired up when a
white guy does something bad so she
looked at ted tarando she was like [ __ ]
him and she literally said uh
she said hey ted sarandos just a quick
note to let you know that i would prefer
if you didn't drag my name into your
mess now i have to deal with even more
of the hate and anger that dave
chappelle's fans like to unleash on me
every time gabe gets 20 million dollars
to process his emotionally stunted
partial world view um
[ __ ] you in your amoral algorithm cult
i do
what with more backbone than you what is
that word uh i can do more s s
[ __ ] shits
i can do more shits
with more backbone than you
what
but this is what i mean she's not she's
not fully with us
she's not fully with us and god bless
her she's a child of god
she goes that's just a joke
i definitely didn't cross alarm because
you just told the world there isn't one
gabs gatsby captured her plus yes i
watched the whole thing leave me alone
trans is beautiful comedy is dead i
killed it those are the hashtags
it said it says here she's trans as well
i didn't know that well
i didn't either i had no i know i had no
idea
does she talk about this in the net i
don't think so i don't remember no right
i don't know
well
i want to see them
both of them hash it out
you know
who cares about any of this
comedy's dumb stop watching it stop
watching comedy specials get a life
truly stop watching comedies but stop
watching specials you have horrible
lives
you have horrible lives
people are doing so much cool [ __ ] on
this planet stop watching a [ __ ]
anybody talk for an hour except this
show
because this is different
but the others out there are wasting
your time not me never would i respect
you
stop turn it off turn it off and turn
this on